comme tu peux le voir il ya aucune
ficelle
comment tu t'appelles au lit
tu peut la reprendre au lit
comment t'as fait ça alors toi tu fais
de la magie juste comme ça
mon père est mort il ya longtemps et ma
mère l'année dernière je vis avec ma
petite sartine c'est l'amour de ma fille
salez
toi tu fait du super boulot et appliqué
un nouveau dealer de coke dans quoi le
cam se pointe sur nos terres et commencé
à écouler sakho comme si je n'existais
pas on va lui rendre une petite ici
ça tourne en un truc pour lequel j'aurai
jamais être j'ai jamais pensé que ça
pourrait devenir dangereux j'aimerais
qu'on habite dans un endroit où il ya de
meilleures écoles ils sont entourés de
personnes bien
rapportant fait jeter sur ce vraiment ce
que tu as fait jeter donner du temps
quand on avait le plus besoin je te
ferai buts et toi et toutes les
personnes que je connais
j'espère rien qui doit inquiéter
c'est un peu difficile d'être adultes
parfois
je sais pas comment tout ça est arrivé
je vais aider à trouver une solution
[Musique]
j'ai continué à améliorer ce nouveau
tour
je fais un truc que personne ne peut
faire à mon dieu
mais il me faut plus de puissance ce
n'est pas pour un tour de magie n'est ce
pas
il ya beaucoup de choses qui peuvent
nous retenir
ces obstacles n'existe que si on les
considère comme tête
on peut faire tout ce qu'on veut il
suffit de croire qu'on en est capable
bowers
[Musique]